[Music]
hi guys i'm anna bohn from simply learn
and today we are going to discuss about
the top ten certifications that might
transform your career for a better
future when employees are looking to
hire or promote education or the
knowledge on a particular technology is
a key factor which is why it's important
to earn certificates in your field in
this video we will be looking into some
of the certifications that can be
important for any professional career
let's see what are the different
certifications we have that are creating
a lot of buzz every day there is a new
company forming and every company needs
to reach out to its customers or clients
the companies use marketing as a medium
to do that these days digital marketing
is that widely used medium Facebook
Google kora and many more social
platforms have become source of digital
marketing digital marketing can be a
field where one can expect a fast growth
in terms of career the certificates
under digital marketing are FB certified
planning professional FB certified
buying professional Google AdWords
certifications and HubSpot content
marketing certifications
first one is FB Certified planning
professional the fee for this
certification is 150 dollars and the
salary that one might expect after
completion is sixty six thousand dollars
approximately entrepreneurs fresh
graduates product manager and digital
marketing executives can get deeply
benefited from this certification and
some of the important topics to be
studied are tracking and reporting
defining advertising objective building
campaign plan and evaluate camping plan
next comes FB Certified buying
professional fee for this certification
is 150 dollars in the salary that one
might expect after completion is sixty
seven thousand dollars approximately
people who might get benefited from this
certification are digital marketing
executives product managers fresh
graduates and some of the important
topics to be studied are pre campaign
assessment tracking and reporting
creative content making troubleshooting
and targeting Google AdWords
certification is available for free and
the salary that one might get after
completion is around $65,000
approximately people who should be doing
this certification our product managers
fresh graduates web marketers and
entrepreneurs some of the important
topics to be studied our AdWords
fundamentals creating PPC ad campaign
sharing budget
and content marketing the last one is
HubSpot content marketing certification
is also available for free and the
salary that one might get after
completion is $65,000 approximately this
certification is for product managers
digital marketing executives and web
marketers and some of the important
topics to be studied a storytelling
content ideas strategy framework
repurposing analysis and effective
writing skills every company's work
depends on the data flowing throughout
various disciplines within it a proper
computer network makes it possible for
the data to flow smoothly thus making it
a very profitable career choice for
anyone the role of a networking
specialist is to maintain the integrity
and the security of a company's network
and the system's connected to it the
certificates under networking are cisco
certified network professional cisco
certified internet work expert Wireshark
certified network analyst and cisco
certified network associate let's talk
about cisco certified network
professional fee for this certifications
is 3,300 dollars and the salary that one
might expect after completing this
course is 41 thousand dollars
approximately people who are IT
technicians entry-level
ingenious network specialist network
administrator and system engineers can
definitely go for this particular
certification and the topics that are
important for this particular
certificate are gateway routing protocol
open shortest path first layer three
path control free for these
certifications one thousand seven
hundred and fifteen dollars and the
salary that one might expect is hundred
thousand dollars approximately people
who are IT technicians entry-level
engineers network specialists can
definitely go for this particular
certification and the things that are
important to be studied our gateway
routing protocol layer 3 path control
ipv6 routing next up is Wireshark
certified Network analyst the fee for
this certification is $29 and the salary
that one might expect is eighty six
thousand dollars approximately it is fit
for people from both technical and
non-technical background and the topics
that are important for this certificate
is functions of tcp/ip networks network
performance network security
configuration of network host packet
loss receiver congestion and network
queuing next is cisco certified network
associate fee for this certification
this 330 dollars in the salary can be
seventy four thousand five hundred
dollars approximately IT technicians
entry-level engineers network
Minna straighter and system engineers
can definitely go for this particular
certification and the important topics
are LAN switching technologies routing
technologies Wan technologies and
network fundamentals in the prison world
every week a company comes across a new
problem and in order to deal with them
new tools are being made these tools
need programming so it can be one of the
major career options for anyone the
certificates under programming are Java
certification c programming language
certified associate microsoft certified
solution developer the java
certification costs to $45 and the
salary that one might expect after
completion is a hundred and two thousand
dollars approximately people looking for
roles in software development and people
looking to upskill can definitely go for
this particular certification and the
important topics to be aware of our Java
fundamentals datatypes loops classes and
arrays c programming language certified
associate this certificate costs to
ninety five dollars and the salary that
one might expect after completion is one
hundred and two thousand dollars
approximately people looking for roles
in software development and people who
are looking to obscure in their career
and go for this certification and the
topics to be studied are basics of C++
files streams arrays and pointers
the last one is Microsoft certified
solution developer fee for this
certification is in 150 dollars and the
salary that one might expect after
completion is a hundred and two thousand
dollars people looking for roles in
software development and people looking
to upskill can go for this certification
and the important topics that one must
be aware of are as your JavaScript html5
css3 C sharp and dotnet project
management project management can play a
very important role in a company as it
ensures that the right kind of projects
are taken up and are delivered on time
as a project manager one should be able
to negotiate reasonable deadlines and
milestones across steams management and
the stakeholders so it is quite obvious
that this can be a very promising choice
of career let's have a look at the
various certifications we have under
project management the very certificates
under project management are project
management professional certified scrum
master and certified associate in
project management let's talk about
project management professional first
fee for this certification is 560
dollars on the salary
that one might expect after completing
this course is $99,000 approx people who
are familiar with dotnet developing and
our team leads and are already certified
associate in project management can
definitely go for this particular
certification scope management schedule
management quality management and risk
management are some of the very
important topics that one should be
familiar with before taking up the
certification the next one is certified
scrum master scrum is a methodology that
allows a team to self organize and make
changes quickly in accordance with agile
principles the scrum master manages the
process for how information is exchanged
free for this certification is twelve
thousand ninety five dollars to nineteen
thousand ninety five and the salary that
one might expect after completing this
course is one hundred one thousand
dollars approximately managers of scrum
team members of scrum team and the
team's transitioning to scrum can
definitely go for this certificate scrum
framework definition of ton running a
scrum project and role of the scrum
master are some of the important topics
that are necessary for this certificate
the last one is certified associate in
project management fee for this
certification just three hundred dollars
and the salary that one might expect is
a hundred and one thousand dollars
approximately people with less project
experience can definitely go for this
particular certification and the topics
that are important for this a project
life cycle in organization integration
management procurement management time
management and quality management DevOps
DevOps is again a practice which has
speed of software development processes
it's done bringing development and
operations team together it is currently
being used in almost all the product
based companies making this line of
career a complete favorite
certifications under this category are
all based on the tools that are used in
DevOps and they are puppet docker chef
Jenkins and salt stack the first one is
puppet free for this certification is
two hundred dollars in the salary that
one might expect after completion is
hundred thousand dollars approximately
people who might get benefited from this
certification are software developers
technical project managers architects an
operation support some of the important
topics in this certification are
peripherals of puppet design puppet
inner core workability
puppet modules with alignments of signal
master then comes docker free for these
certifications is
ninety-five dollars in the salary after
completion is hundred thousand dollars
approximately this certification can be
good for software developers technical
project managers architects an operation
support and some of the important topics
to be studied a container security
configuration management tools Linux or
Windows Server and experience on any one
cloud provider the next one is chef free
for this certification can range from
$75 to one hundred and seventy-five
dollars and the salary that one might
get after completion is 90 thousand
dollars approximately people who might
get benefited from this certification
are software developers technical
project managers architects and
operation support and some of the
important topics to be studied our
understanding chef's resources share
server chef cookbooks chef rows and
environments and desired state
configuration fee for this certification
is $200 in the salary that one might get
after completion is $95,000
approximately software developers
technical project managers architects
and operations support can get benefited
from this particular certification some
of the important topics to be studied
Archy continuous delivery continuous
integration concepts Jenkins usages and
building CD pipelines
the last one is salt stack fee for this
certification is 350 dollars in the
salary that one might expect after
completion is $95,000 approximately
software developers technical project
managers architects an operation support
are some of the people who might get
benefited from this particular
certification some of the important
topics to be studied are understanding
the concepts of salt cloud salt
command-line basics of states and state
formulas with the ever increasing number
of cyber criminals in the ways they come
in cybercrime cyber security is
something that the world will need for
years to come every company has
information of its client and employees
which it cannot afford to leak
that's where cyber security is very
important this can be a happening career
choice the certificates under cyber
security are certified information
security manager certified information
systems auditor and certified
information systems security
professional first up is certified
information security manager its role is
to monitor security operations of the
company and the fee for this
certification is for sixty-five dollars
and the salary that one might expect is
close to 120 eight thousand dollars
approximately people who might get
benefited from the certification are
security consulting
security auditors and architects and IT
managers and some of the important
topics to be studied are security
architecture information security
network security incident management etc
the role of a certified information
systems auditor is to collect evidence
of a company's information systems
practices and operations fee for this
certification is for sixty five dollars
in the salary that one might expect
after completion is eighty seven
thousand dollars approximately IT
auditors highly managers and security
architects will get benefited from this
particular certification and some of the
important topics to be studied are
auditing information system governance
and management of IT information system
acquisition and protection of
information assets
the last one is certified information
systems security professional fee for
this certification is $6.99 dollars and
the salary that one might expect after
completion is 81 thousand dollars
approximately people who might get
benefited from this certification are IT
managers security auditors Network
architects and security consultants and
some of the important topics to be
studied are design and security
architecture application development
security and cryptography business
intelligence business intelligence tools
are used by companies to monitor data
and figure out significant event and
changes in the company's growth and
business so anyone who is familiar with
the working of the BI tools can be an
asset for any company let's look at some
of the certifications certificates under
BI tools are tableau informatica SAS SAP
bi certification and click view tableau
is a data visualization tool and the fee
might vary from 250 dollars to $800 and
the salary that one might get after
completion is $75,000 approximately this
certification in tableau might be
beneficial for data analysts data
scientists
bi and reporting professionals and
software developers and some of the
important topics to be studied in
tableau are building dashboards tableau
statistics data blending and mapping
concepts then comes informatica fee for
this certification just to $40 and
salary would round up to $80,000
approximately ETL and data warehouse
professionals SQL and database
developers bi professionals and software
developers are some of the people who
might get benefitted from this
certificate and some of the important
topics to be studied our understanding
admin console creating
mappings transformation functions and
expression syntax a certification on
sass would cost $180 in the salary that
one might expect after completion is
$80,000 approximately some of the people
who might get benefited from a sass
certification are those looking for
career in in analytics data analysts SQL
developers and bi professionals and some
of the important topics to be studied
are analyzing and manipulating data
items with SAS visual analytics
exploding data with SAS and creating
report content using SAS visual
analytics designer then comes SAP bi
certification free for these
certifications is $500 in the salary
that one might expect after completion
is a hundred and ten thousand dollars
approximately people who might get
benefitted from this certification are
software developers data analysts
professionals ETL and data warehouse
professionals and BI professionals some
of the important topics to be studied
are query designer integrated planning
so systems infoprovider and data
warehousing and modeling techniques
the last one is click view the fee for
this particular course is 250 dollars
and the salary that one might get after
completion is $70,000 approximately
people who might get benefitted from
this certification
ETL and data warehouse professionals
data analysts professionals software
developers and SQL and database
developers some of the important topics
to be studied on QlikView are analyzing
reports and adding visualization
optimized data models using advanced
script functions and understanding data
layers with qvd files big data is not a
technology but a practice a practice
that helps in analyzing a massive amount
of data this data cannot be handled by
traditional tools since making big data
are very important it helps in finding
information from a data that is highly
complex and unstructured any
professional who is good with any of the
big data tools can think of taking up a
certification on this category and get
up skilled the certificates under big
data are CC a spark and Hadoop developer
CCA administrator
HDB certified administrator SAS
certified Big Data Professional and HD
be certified Apache spark starting off
with CC a spark and Hadoop developer fee
for this certification is 295 dollars in
the salary that one might expect can be
120 thousand dollars
ultimately people who are systems
developer data engineers database
administrators and IT systems engineers
can definitely go for this particular
certificate and the important things to
be studied in this certification are
hadoop MySQL SPARC data analysis data
filter using spark and ETL processes
next is CCA administrator fee for this
certification
Moose's to $95 and the salary can go up
to seventy eight thousand dollars
approximately this course can be
beneficial for IT systems engineers
back-end developers data analytics
administrator cloud systems
administrators important topics to be
studied for this particular
certification are setting up local CDH
repository installing CDH configuring
name nodes and rebalancing clusters HDPE
certified administrator fee for this
certification uses 250 dollars and the
salary can go up to a whopping 120
thousand dollars approximately people
who are either system engineers back-end
developers data analytics administrator
can definitely go for this particular
certification and the important topics
to be studied are hadoop components
cluster basics Resource Management SD of
his operations next one is SAS certified
big data professional fee for these
certifications is 180 dollars and the
Saturday can go up to hundred and eleven
thousand dollars approximately people
who can get benefitted from this
certification
are IT systems engineers back-end
developers data analytics administrator
and cloud system administrators and the
important topics to be studied our SAS
programming Hadoop hive statistics and
analytics
the last one is HDPE certified apache
spark fee for this certification is 250
dollars and the salary can go up to 96
thousand dollars approximately again IT
system engineers back-end developers
data analytics administrator cloud
systems administrators can get benefited
from this certificate and some of the
important topics to be studied for this
certification are apache spark
python hive and creating RDD next up is
cloud computing simply put cloud
computing is computing based on the
Internet
previously companies had to use software
downloaded into a physical computer or
server in the building the wake of cloud
computing allows people to work on the
same applications through the internet
from different systems given the fact
that cloud computing has become one of
the technologies used in each and every
company going for a certification on
this would be a good
the certificates under cloud computing
are AWS certified solution architect
Google cloud certified cloud architect
and Microsoft Azure let's start off with
AWS certified solution architect the
solution architect translates
requirements created by functional
analysts into the architecture for the
solution fee for this certification this
is three hundred dollars and the salary
that one might expect after completion
is one hundred and sixteen dollars
approximately people who work on AWS
based applications and can deploy hybrid
system using AWS and can build a double
O's applications can definitely go for
this particular certification some of
the topics important for this
certification are databases an AWS
identity management and access
management next up is Google cloud
certified cloud architect a cloud
architect is an IT specialist who is
responsible for deploying and overseeing
a company's cloud computing strategy
free for these certifications is $200
and the salary that one might expect is
to $48,000 approximately people who want
to build a career out of cloud computing
can definitely go for this particular
certificate and the topics that are
important for this certificate or cloud
architecture cloud security cloud
infrastructure solution and operation
reliability Microsoft Azure is a tool
used to manage cloud based applications
the fee for this certification is 165
dollars in the salary that one might
expect after completing it is 118
thousand dollars approximately DevOps or
QA engineers team leads and people who
are familiar with dotnet developing can
go for this particular certification and
the topics that are important for this
particular certificate are
implementation management of is your app
services and managing virtual machines
data science is a field in which
processes and systems are used to
extract insights from a complicated data
companies have recently realized how
important this field is to informing
their day-to-day decisions so getting
into data science can be a very wise
decision the various certificates under
data science are clouded a certified
professional data engineer data
scientist associate certified analytics
professional and John Hopkins data
science certification starting off with
clouded a certified professional data
engineer the role of a data engineer is
to design construct install test and
maintain data management systems free
for these certifications is $400 and the
salary that one can expect after
completion is hung
an $11,000 approximately and people who
might get benefited from this
certification a software developers
analytics professionals people
interested in a career in analytics and
project managers and the important
topics to be studied for the certificate
are Hadoop
our DBMS hive statistics the role of the
data scientist associate is to collect
different data analyze them and make
decisions based on them fee for these
certifications $200 in the salary that
one might expect after completion is
$60,000 approx software developers
analytics professionals people
interested in a career in analytics can
definitely go for this particular
certification some of the important
topics to be studied for this
certification are Java Python Perl and
SQL then comes certified analytics
professional the fee for this course is
695 dollars and the salary that one
might get after completion is 150
thousand dollars approximately software
developers analytics professionals
people interested in a career in in
analytics and project managers might get
benefited from this certification and
the important topics to be studied our
business problem framing analytics
problems framing model deployment and
lifecycle management the last one is
John Hopkins data science certification
the fee for the certification is for $90
and the salary that one might expect
after completion is 130 thousand dollars
approximately software developers
analytics professional and people
interested in a career in analytics can
definitely go for this particular
certification and the important topics
that one should know our programming
analytics statistics machine learning
and data science capstone now that you
know how certificates can help you up
skill in your career here is how simply
learn can help simply learn has a
certification on project management
cloud computing networking big data BI
tools cybersecurity digital marketing
programming DevOps and data science so
log on to simply learn to take your
first step get certified and get ahead I
hope you guys liked the video and found
it helpful enough thank you and stay
tuned for more videos
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos Turner DUP and get certified
click here